Hello and welcome to a special bonus episode of how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎收看我们如何造就你母亲的特别奖励剧集。
I am Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am joined as ever by my good friend and how I met your mother co-creator Craig Thomas.
我的好朋友一如既往地加入了我的行列，以及我如何认识你的母亲共同创造者克雷格·托马斯。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
And this is a these are episodes that we call general questions, general questions, general questions.
这是一个我们称之为一般问题、一般问题、一般问题的情节。
I was waiting for you.
我在等你。
It's always a leg.
永远都是一条腿。
I was trying so hard and I was going to.
我非常努力，我也要去。
Hi.
你好。
I was.
我是。
Try it again.
再试一次。
This is just a bit of what we call general questions.
这只是我们所说的一般性问题的一部分。
General questions.
一般问题。
We're never.
我们从来都不是。
No, but that was a little better.
不，但这样好一点。
I think it's actually like Einstein terms, time, the time of the space, time continuum.
我认为这实际上就像爱因斯坦的术语，时间，空间的时间，时间连续体。
I think we did do it all at the same moment.
我认为我们确实在同一时刻完成了这一切。
We just had to wait for it to go into space and come back.
我们只需要等待它进入太空并返回。
Here's how I hear it.
我是这样听到的。
This is how we did it on the show.
我们在节目中就是这样做的。
I'm just honoring, and I know Alec, you created this in some of the ancient past.
我只是向你致敬，我知道亚历克，你在远古时代创造了这个。
But I say, that's a general questions beat, general questions.
但我想说，这是一个一般性的问题，一般性的问题。
There's a lot you have to just honor a beat.
有很多事情你必须尊重节拍。
I panic in the beat.
我在节拍中惊慌失措。
It can't be too long.
不可能太长。
You panic, you give too long a beat, Craig.
你惊慌失措，你的节奏太长了，克雷格。
Yeah.
是的。
I know.
我知道。
It's I know.
这是我知道的
General questions.
一般问题。
Yeah.
是的。
See Josh and I are getting, it's Craig.
看到乔什和我正在接受，这是克雷格。
We've figured this out.
我们已经弄清楚了。
Yeah.
是的。
I'll take the head.
我来拿头。
All right.
好的。
Someone, by the way, I don't know who it is.
顺便说一句，我不知道是谁。
Someone put a, did a super cut of us fucking out.
有人放了一张我们他妈的超级剪辑。
Let's fucking it out.
让我们把它搞砸吧。
Did you put that on Instagram or something?
你把它放在 Instagram 或者其他什么地方了吗？
I shared it, I liked it, I did something.
我分享了它，我喜欢它，我做了一些事情。
I clicked a button.
我点击了一个按钮。
Well, thank you for that.
嗯，谢谢你。
Now am I screwing it up?
现在我搞砸了吗？
Or am I a geniously, ingeniously extending a runner?
或者我是一个天才、巧妙的跑步者？
No. Who could say?
不，谁能说呢？
Well, you just want the bit to go on.
好吧，你只是想让这件事继续下去。
Your comedy brain is like, we got nine seasons, yeah.
你的喜剧大脑会说，我们有九季，是的。
I see it as material, I'm hearing it.
我将其视为材料，我正在听到它。
So we're following up with some additional stuff around episode nine, Belly Full of Turkey, written by Chris Miller and Phil Lord.
因此，我们正在跟进第九集《满腹火鸡》的一些额外内容，由克里斯·米勒和菲尔·洛德撰写。
And what do we got, Alec?
我们得到了什么，亚历克？
We went pretty deep on this episode last time, but let's finish it off and...
上次我们对这一集进行了相当深入的探讨，但让我们结束它吧……
Laning around.
绕行。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, we did.
好吧，我们做到了。
We got a few questions here.
我们在这里有几个问题。
Something that I'm gonna, I have a question.
我想做点什么，我有一个问题。
I'm just gonna point out that once you, once we went to the store, We're seven, 11, where did Lily go?
我只是想指出，一旦你，一旦我们去了商店，我们七岁，十一岁，莉莉去哪儿了？
I'm sorry, I didn't watch the show, I don't watch TV.
对不起，我没看节目，我不看电视。
I don't remember what it was named and I've watched it many times, but it's a convenience store and so outside, so that's his name.
我不记得它叫什么了，我已经看过很多次了，但那是一家便利店，而且在外面，所以这就是他的名字。
Do I do the convenience store?
我开便利店吗？
There's a jail, all of a sudden I start going, how many sets were in this episode?
有监狱，突然就开​​始了，这一集有多少集？
There's a lot, there's a lot.
有很多，有很多。
I mean, this would have been a week where, see this is fun to talk about how amazing our crew was, how amazing our set designers were, amazing how things had to be jingled around and just like there wasn't it's a big sound stage stage 22 on the Fox lot still think of it as our stage I don't know who's there right now but get out it's ours and they would have to when we'd have this many sets almost surely have had to like overnight dismantle one or two of these sets to put in other ones right because you have all you have multiple spots within the Erickson the Erickson household Then you have the jail cell, you have the convenience store, you have the Thanksgiving, the charity place, where the food, the soup kitchen place, and that's two rooms, right?
我的意思是，这将是一个很有趣的一周，看到这很有趣，谈论我们的工作人员是多么出色，我们的布景设计师是多么出色，东西必须叮当作响，就像没有一样，福克斯地段的22号大摄影棚仍然认为它是我们的舞台，我不知道现在谁在那儿，但出去它是我们的，当我们有这么多布景时，他们几乎肯定不得不在一夜之间拆除其中的一两个设置正确的其他位置，因为您拥有所有埃里克森埃里克森家庭中的多个位置然后您有牢房，您有便利店，您有感恩节，慈善场所，食物，流动厨房的地方，那是两个房间，对吗？
There's like a backstage and then they have Ted runs out and thrown the mushrooms out.
就像一个后台，然后他们让特德跑出去把蘑菇扔出去。
That's another, and it isn't everything else.
那是另一回事，但并不是其他的一切。
I'm maybe even leaving some out that there's no way that all fit and just stayed there for three days for sure the set magic was happening.
我什至可能会遗漏一些，因为不可能一切都适合，只是在那里呆了三天以确保设定的魔法发生。
I always found it incredible that you would go home at night.
我总觉得你晚上回家真是不可思议。
You've come back the next morning and there's an entire, it's gone.
第二天早上你回来时，整个东西都消失了。
New house built.
新房子建成了。
Like it was extraordinary.
就像它很非凡一样。
Like how quickly they would tear it one thing down.
就像他们能多快地把它拆掉一样。
And also like, this is maybe for people who wanna believe a little more deeply in the fiction of it, might not please you.
而且，这可能适合那些想更深入地相信它的虚构的人，可能不会让你高兴。
But, so you're in the soup kitchen, right?
但是，所以你在施粥厨房里，对吗？
And in New York and you walk 20 feet to your left and you're in St.
在纽约，你向左走 20 英尺，你就到了圣路易斯。
Cloud, Minnesota.
明尼苏达州克劳德。
And then you turn around and you're staring at Ted Marshall's apartment.
然后你转过身，看到泰德·马歇尔的公寓。
And then you walk 20 feet to the left and you're in McLaren's bar.
然后您向左走 20 英尺，就到了迈凯伦酒吧。
One thing I wanted to say that struck me as funny that I forgot to mention, there's something funny.
我想说的一件事让我觉得很有趣，但我忘了提及，有一些有趣的事情。
And it's kind of a convention that people use and we've used it a couple times, I think I don't remember, but like when Lily has her breakdown in the convenience store, like it's clearly just like a high school kid, like with a job, like trying to do his best, you know, it's like, he's got this like sad person thrown in his lap and he has to suddenly be like a therapist to her.
这是人们使用的一种惯例，我们用过几次，我想我不记得了，但是就像莉莉在便利店崩溃时一样，就像一个高中生一样，就像工作一样，就像努力做到最好，你知道，就像，他把一个悲伤的人扔在他的腿上，他必须突然像她的治疗师一样。
I think that I just thought that was really funny.
我想我只是觉得这真的很有趣。
I thought that guy was good.
我以为那家伙很好。
He was really good.
他真的很好。
He was great.
他很棒。
You are taller than described.
你比描述的要高。
I really love that one.
我真的很喜欢那个。
Right, and also the thing of like- This happens when Paul Erickson's are always telling everyone that Marshall's got this tiny little thing of a girl back into your- Yeah, but also like this small town, like everyone knows everything.
是的，还有类似的事情——当保罗·埃里克森总是告诉每个人马歇尔把这个小女孩带回了你的身边时，就会发生这种情况——是的，但也像这个小镇一样，就像每个人都知道一切一样。
Yeah, everyone knows everything.
是的，每个人都知道一切。
Everyone knows.
每个人都知道。
Oh, you know, the Erickson's.
哦，你知道，埃里克森家。
It's just that the flavor of that was fantastic.
只是那个味道太棒了。
Perfectly, you know, that was really good.
完美，你知道，那真的很好。
Would have been nice to learn his name, but we didn't.
如果能知道他的名字就好了，但我们没有。
But hey, you're a good guy.
但是嘿，你是个好人。
You know who you are.
你知道你是谁。
Becky Strauss, 11 asks, can you talk about the inspiration behind Marshall's love from Minnesota and the Vikings and his two brothers and everything Marshall Erickson.
11 岁的贝基·施特劳斯 (Becky Strauss) 问，您能谈谈马歇尔对明尼苏达州、维京人队以及他的两个兄弟以及马歇尔·埃里克森 (Marshall Erickson) 的一切的热爱背后的灵感吗？
Where did Minnesota, is that where Jason's from?
明尼苏达州在哪里，杰森来自哪里？
No, no, Jason's from LA and the character's little parts of the character, of course, based on me and I am from Long Island.
不，不，杰森来自洛杉矶，角色的小部分当然是基于我，而我来自长岛。
So now it was, you know, we had some Midwesterners represented on the writing staff early on.
所以现在，你知道，我们早期的写作团队中有一些中西部人。
Was Chuck Tatham already on the show?
查克·塔瑟姆已经在节目中了吗？
Chuck Tatham wasn't on the show yet.
查克·塔瑟姆还没有出现在节目中。
What's funny is Chuck Tatham, a very funny writer, joined a few seasons in and was as a Canadian.
有趣的是查克·塔瑟姆（Chuck Tatham），一位非常有趣的作家，以加拿大人的身份加入了几季。
He, from just outside near Toronto and Guelph, and he's a very funny Canadian as it's so often the case with Canadians.
他来自多伦多和圭尔夫附近，是一个非常有趣的加拿大人，因为加拿大人经常遇到这种情况。
They seem a little extra funny and brilliant and he was those things and he but he had you know he's just over the border there in Toronto and there were people in his world that would be fans of the Minnesota Vikings.
他们看起来有点特别有趣和聪明，他就是这些东西，但他让你知道他就在多伦多边境，在他的世界里有人会是明尼苏达维京人队的球迷。
Like there wasn't that huge of a trip to like you could get in there and sort of like travel and go to a Vikings game which he did a bunch of times.
就像没有那么大的旅行一样，你可以去那里，有点像旅行，去看维京人队的比赛，他已经去过很多次了。
He became this lifelong Vikings fan despite being a Canadian and so everything about Marshall loving the Vikings came from Chuck Chuck Tatham was legitimately a hardcore Vikings fan since childhood.
尽管他是加拿大人，但他却成为了维京人队的终身粉丝，因此马歇尔热爱维京人队的一切都来自查克 查克·塔瑟姆（Chuck Tatham）从小就是一名铁杆维京人队球迷。
But why was Marshall from Minnesota?
但为什么马歇尔来自明尼苏达呢？
I think we just arrived at it.
我想我们刚刚做到了。
We thought Lily is a Brooklyn girl, right?
我们以为莉莉是布鲁克林女孩，对吗？
We don't want to hit Marshall also to be from New York.
我们不想让马歇尔也来自纽约。
We just wanted them to be from two different worlds and meeting at Wesleyan.
我们只是希望他们来自两个不同的世界并在卫斯理安会面。
We didn't want it to be too similar to Ohio.
我们不希望它与俄亥俄州太相似。
We knew we wanted Ted to be from Ohio, like Josh, Kobe's Canadian.
我们知道我们希望特德来自俄亥俄州，就像乔什一样，科比的加拿大人。
I think we just landed on Minnesota.
我想我们刚刚降落在明尼苏达州。
It wasn't because anyone from the writing staff was literally from there.
这并不是因为写作人员中的任何人都来自那里。
We just thought it's a world.
我们只是以为这是一个世界。
It's a world to explore.
这是一个值得探索的世界。
It's a cool other world and energy than we have in the group.
这是一个比我们在团队中更酷的另一个世界和能量。
So that's why we did it.
这就是我们这样做的原因。
You know, it strikes me that you make these decisions and you might make them pretty flippantly or off-handedly, just like, it could be as casual as like, what about Minnesota?
你知道，让我印象深刻的是，你做出这些决定时，你可能会非常轻率或随意地做出这些决定，就像，它可能很随意，就像明尼苏达州怎么样？
And someone's like, yeah, yeah, let's do Minnesota.
有人说，是啊，是啊，我们就去明尼苏达州吧。
Then you do a show for nine years and Minnesota becomes like a pretty consequential choice.
然后你做了九年的演出，明尼苏达就成为一个非常重要的选择。
Like, Minnesota fuels a lot of comedy, Minnesota is, yeah, it just becomes a bigger deal because of the longevity of the show.
就像，明尼苏达州催生了很多喜剧，明尼苏达州是的，由于该剧的长寿，它变得更重要。
Totally, and it inspires whole episodes.
完全如此，它激发了整个情节。
There's a whole episode about finding a Minnesota Vikings bar in New York City.
有整整一集是关于在纽约市寻找明尼苏达维京人队酒吧的。
It's like, that's just because of some random, we sort of threw a dart at the map of America and arrived at that, and it becomes this defining thing about Marshall and his love of the Vikings and the flavor of who his family is, and all these things, it is amazing.
就好像，这只是因为一些随机性，我们在美国地图上扔了一个飞镖，然后到达了那里，它成为马歇尔和他对维京人的热爱以及他的家人的味道的决定性因素，所有这些事情，这是令人惊奇的。
You are, TV is building the car while you're driving it, right?
你是的，当你驾驶汽车时，电视正在建造汽车，对吧？
you're never ceasing to build the new parts of that car, but it has to also remain in motion the entire time.
你永远不会停止建造那辆车的新零件，但它也必须始终保持运转。
And it's that's kind of what's hard about it, and it's what's thrilling and wonderful about it too.
这就是它的困难之处，也是它令人兴奋和美妙的地方。
I always felt Jason had a particular glint in his eye around that family, like when those brothers would show up in the font, like, I don't know, I think one Jason, like he kind of got a kick out of being like the run of the litter because he's always the tallest person.
我总觉得杰森在那个家庭周围有一种特别的光芒，就像当那些兄弟出现在字体中时，就像，我不知道，我认为杰森，就像他因为像垃圾一样而感到高兴，因为他总是最高的人。
And it was just, I could really tell that he enjoyed those Minnesota scenes, you know.
只是，我真的可以看出他很喜欢明尼苏达的那些场景，你知道。
So funny.
太有趣了。
That's three months old, baby.
宝宝已经三个月了。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like clearly one year.
显然是一年了。
So all of that stuff was so, so funny.
所以所有这些事情都非常非常有趣。
And Jason was energized by that story.
杰森被这个故事激励了。
He likes the idea that he got to go be in this whole other world, but it's not his own world.
他喜欢这样的想法：他必须去另一个世界，但这不是他自己的世界。
And that's, yeah, it's not based on Jason, even though Ted and Robin are both like, right?
是的，这不是基于杰森，尽管泰德和罗宾都很像，对吧？
we made their hometowns match.
我们让他们的家乡相匹配。
Your guys actual hometowns.
你们这些人真正的家乡。
Kobe, you retrofitted it to her.
科比，你为她改装了它。
You made her from Canada after it.
之后你就让她从加拿大来了。
I heard it's from Ohio.
听说是俄亥俄州的
Carter's from Ohio.
卡特来自俄亥俄州。
It's from Ohio.
来自俄亥俄州。
I stepped in and it was somewhat coincidental that I also happened to have.
我介入了，有点巧合的是，我也碰巧遇到了。
It's just his men, yeah, it's true.
这只是他的手下，是的，这是事实。
I think it didn't hurt me getting the role.
我认为这并没有影响我获得这个角色。
But yeah, that's what I mean.
但是，是的，这就是我的意思。
It was like so right away, you were also Ohio that it feels, it feels of a piece.
就好像你也是俄亥俄州，感觉就像是一体的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you.
我给你写了这首小曲来唱给你听。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock, and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能在 Bravo's Summer House 认识我，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我会不分昼夜地邀请您最喜欢的真人秀明星，并参与您通常听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
深层的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、德林达·梅德利 (Derinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsey Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships, growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们会陷入人际关系、成长、混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周播放一集 More Life，无论您在哪里收听播客或在 YouTube 上观看。
I was noticing Kobe in this one who plays a very, um, a true straight man, straight woman, straight man, yes, ending the whole thing.
我注意到科比在这部电影中扮演了一个非常，嗯，一个真正的直男，直女，直男，是的，结束了整个事情。
There's nothing she doesn't break in terms of, isn't it weird that we're here in this soup kitchen and bar?
没有什么是她不破坏的，我们在这个施食厨房和酒吧里不是很奇怪吗？
Isn't it weird that we're here in a strip club?
我们在脱衣舞俱乐部是不是很奇怪？
She just, she plays it so nicely.
她只是，她演得很好。
Just, yep, yep, this is what we're doing.
只是，是的，是的，这就是我们正在做的事情。
along for the radio right now yeah yeah and a joe little ask of this is nice what was it like working with bill fagrbocky did i pronounce that correct yeah fagrbocky as a nineties two thousand skid i was just here patrick stars voice but he played marshall dead so well he was perfectly cast and he quotes uh...
现在在广播电台是的，是的，乔一点点问这个很好，和比尔·法格博基一起工作是什么感觉，我发音正确吗，是的，法格博基作为一个九十两千的滑行者，我只是在这里帕特里克明星的声音，但他扮演马歇尔死得如此之好，他是完美的演员，他引用了呃......
plane food is ass tells about tells a bill who was with you for quite a while well wasn't he he was on coach right he was on coach he was domber on coach and and he was in SpongeBob.
飞机上的食物是屁股讲述的，讲述了一个账单，他和你在一起有一段时间了，不是他，他在教练上，对吗，他在教练上，他在教练上很闷闷不乐，而且他在海绵宝宝里。
He's so funny and good in that episode.
他在那一集中非常有趣而且很好。
And like, not to tell, this is the gossipy part of us and I won't name names, but we had somebody else cast in that role who we wound up letting go of very last minute.
而且，不说，这是我们八卦的一部分，我不会点名，但我们有其他人扮演这个角色，我们最终在最后一刻放弃了。
To be Marshall's dad, it didn't work.
作为马歇尔的父亲，这是行不通的。
Like we were rehearsing for the episode.
就像我们正在排练这一集一样。
There were some personality clashes, Josh, do you remember this at all?
其中存在一些性格冲突，乔什，你还记得这件事吗？
Do you know what I'm talking about?
你知道我在说什么吗？
I'm not gonna name the names.
我不会说出这些名字。
I know you heard it, yes.
我知道你听到了，是的。
We're not gonna name names, but yes, there was another, Also another kind of somewhat legendary TV actor.
我们不会说出名字，但是，是的，还有另一个，也是另一种有点传奇的电视演员。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Right?
正确的？
We can't name it.
我们无法说出它的名字。
It would be crappy to name names, but it just, there was a personality conflict.
说出来名字确实很蹩脚，但也只是性格冲突罢了。
Kind of, it just wasn't fitting.
有点，它只是不合适。
The energy wasn't fitting.
能量不合适。
I do remember coming in the next day and him being gone.
我确实记得第二天我来的时候他就走了。
And it being like, it wasn't like one person thought he should leave.
就好像，没有人认为他应该离开。
It was like, everyone was like, no, no, no, he was dangerous to the help of safety.
就像，每个人都说，不，不，不，他对安全的帮助是危险的。
Okay, it's fine, it was Kevin Spacey.
好吧，没关系，是凯文·史派西。
I'll just say it.
我就简单说一下吧。
Yeah, but no, I wasn't there obviously for like when it went down.
是的，但是不，当事情发生时我显然不在场。
Or maybe I was because it was like a weird run through, but because he was, I don't think he shot anything, right?
或者也许我是因为这就像一次奇怪的冲刺，但因为他是，我认为他没有开枪，对吧？
He was replacing.
他正在替换。
No, he didn't do anything.
不，他什么也没做。
It was, but that's how last, like that's, that's why I feel like I have to talk about it and answer that question because we were in a freaking panic.
是的，但这就是最后的情况，就像那样，这就是为什么我觉得我必须谈论它并回答这个问题，因为我们陷入了恐慌。
We were like, what are we going to do?
我们当时想，我们要做什么？
You have to shoot this hugely important role that's probably gonna recur in series.
你必须拍摄这个非常重要的角色，它可能会在连续剧中重复出现。
And think of that, it recurred beautifully in series.
想想看，它在系列中完美地重复出现。
And there's big shit that happens with Marshall's dad later in series.
在接下来的剧集中，马歇尔的父亲发生了一些大事。
And you have to love him.
而且你必须爱他。
You have to love Marshall's dad.
你必须爱马歇尔的父亲。
You have to care for him.
你必须照顾他。
You have to know Marshall adores this man.
你必须知道马歇尔很崇拜这个人。
And Marshall is who he is because of this guy.
马歇尔就是因为这个人而成为现在的他。
And boy, would that not have worked with the actor that we fired from?
天哪，这对被我们解雇的演员不起作用吗？
It just wasn't happening.
它只是没有发生。
It wasn't clicking.
它没有点击。
There was, it was just weird.
确实有，这很奇怪。
And I mean, we probably got Bill Fagerbocki in the span of half a day.
我的意思是，我们可能在半天内就找到了比尔·法格博基。
We just reached down to him.
我们刚刚向他伸出手。
I don't know if maybe it was like a last minute idea.
我不知道这是否是最后一刻的想法。
Had we had that idea sooner, I feel like we would have cast him.
如果我们早点有这个想法，我觉得我们就会选择他。
He's so great.
他太棒了。
I don't know why we didn't just start there.
我不知道为什么我们不从那里开始。
I don't, I wish I remembered it would be such a better story if I can remember, but we was a last minute idea.
我不知道，我希望我能记得，如果我能记得的话，这将是一个更好的故事，但我们是最后一刻的想法。
We're like, yes, him.
我们就像，是的，他。
Sometimes as an actor, I actually like to be the last minute solution to people's problems.
有时作为一名演员，我实际上喜欢在最后一刻解决人们的问题。
because you don't feel like you're going up against every other actor in the world.
因为你不会觉得自己是在与世界上所有其他演员对抗。
You actually feel like, oh, they're in trouble and I think I might be the guy.
你实际上会觉得，哦，他们有麻烦了，我想我可能就是那个人。
Like I think I might be the answer to their prayers.
就像我想我可能是他们祈祷的答案。
So there's something almost nice about being the guy who actually just happened to be available when you needed him and it turned into a great multi-year gig for him.
所以，当你需要他的时候，他恰好可以出现，这对他来说是一件很棒的多年工作，这几乎是件好事。
But it's kind of, to me it's like, however you get a role is the right way to get a role.
但对我来说，无论如何你得到一个角色都是得到一个角色的正确方式。
Like that's just how it happened.
就像事情就是这样发生的。
It was meant to be in some way.
它本来就是以某种方式存在的。
It was meant to be a very convoluted process.
这本来是一个非常复杂的过程。
It wasn't like he had, I don't think he had come in an audition and we didn't cast him.
事实并非如此，我认为他没有参加过试镜，我们也没有选他。
God, I hope I'm not wrong about that.
天哪，我希望我没有弄错。
But we, I think it was just like, he's great.
但我们，我认为这就像，他很棒。
Maybe somebody knew him, Pam, for I'm a new him, somebody knew him, and said, I bet if we called Bill, he'd show up in three hours from now and just jump in and yes and this motherfucker.
也许有人认识他，帕姆，因为我是一个新的他，有人认识他，然后说，我打赌如果我们打电话给比尔，他会在三个小时后出现，然后跳进去，是的，还有这个混蛋。
He had that kind of energy of like real like, like utility man on the team.
他拥有那种真正的能量，就像团队中的杂工一样。
Like we'd just do anything to get the.
就像我们会做任何事情来得到一样。
Yeah, so joyful and warm and everything you needed out of that role.
是的，如此快乐和温暖，以及你从这个角色中所需要的一切。
Susie Plakston.
苏西·普拉克斯顿。
She was wonderful, always wonderful, I thought.
我想，她很棒，一直很棒。
She was such a good choice for Marshall's mom.
对于马歇尔的妈妈来说，她是一个很好的选择。
She seemed like Marshall's mom.
她看起来像马歇尔的妈妈。
I don't know, she just really, I know she's supposed to, that's her job, but she was wonderful.
我不知道，她只是真的，我知道她应该这样做，那是她的工作，但她很棒。
They were A-plus, they were A-plus, Bill and Susie.
他们是A+，他们是A+，比尔和苏西。
And how about her take when Lily says she's not gonna take the name?
当莉莉说她不会接受这个名字时，她的看法又如何呢？
And she's like, but the apron's.
她就像，但围裙的。
Like I made you a Mrs. Erickson apron, you have to now be named to that.
就像我给你做了一条埃里克森夫人围裙一样，你现在必须以它的名字命名。
How will this work?
这将如何运作？
She's so innocent and scandalized and are sort of hurt in that moment.
她是如此的天真和震惊，在那一刻有点受伤。
She's funny.
她很有趣。
She's probably six feet tall.
她大概有六英尺高。
She was so tall and maybe a taller and hilarious and perfect with Bill.
她很高，也许还更高，而且很搞笑，和比尔很完美。
You just, I mean, we just, the casting gods frowned upon us and then smiled upon us all within 24 hours.
你只是，我是说，我们只是，铸造之神对我们皱起了眉头，然后在 24 小时内对我们所有人微笑。
And then we had Bill for the rest of the series and got to do some really emotional stuff with him later and God, were we lucky that he had those chops and that warms to merit, then you know, to support that storyline later.
然后我们让比尔参与了该系列的其余部分，并在后来与他做了一些非常情感化的事情，天啊，如果我们幸运的话，他有这些印章和温暖的价值，那么你知道，以后可以支持这个故事情节。
And I won't say what it all is, but.
我不会说这一切是什么，但是。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
I wanted to point out, maybe have you guys talk about someone that we don't talk about very much in this show, which is Ebben Hamm and the Stand-Ins and Ebben's cameo at the end of this, at the end of this show.
我想指出的是，也许你们谈论了一个我们在这个节目中很少谈论的人，那就是埃本·哈姆和替身以及埃本在节目最后的客串。
I mean, he was with you guys for the entire time.
我的意思是，他一直和你们在一起。
Evan who plays, who's so good as the sheriff or the jail warden, he's really good.
扮演的埃文，作为警长或监狱长，他真的很棒。
But Evan was the stand-in for Marshall, for Jason, right?
但埃文是马歇尔、杰森的替身，对吗？
For many, many years, like since day one, he did all nine years on the show.
很多很多年了，就像从第一天开始，他在节目中度过了整整九年。
To explain what that is for people, that's the way when things are camera blocked and rehearsed and different things, Evan would sort of like do, you know, Jason would sort of step out of rehearsal and Evan would sort of do the camera blocking with the cameraman with lighting.
为了解释这对人们来说意味着什么，这就是当镜头被遮挡和排练以及不同的事情时的方式，埃文会有点像这样做，你知道，杰森会退出排练，而埃文会用灯光与摄影师一起挡住摄像机。
So they would like to frame the shots, yeah.
所以他们想拍摄照片，是的。
Yeah, but so much more than that too, because they ebb in and like Gita and like, we have these, we had a wonderful group of stands, Ron Niccolosi, may he rest in peace.
是的，但还不止这些，因为他们在衰退，就像吉塔一样，我们有这些，我们有一群很棒的看台，罗恩·尼科洛西，愿他安息。
We had all these wonderful people that were really part of the team.
我们拥有所有这些优秀的人，他们都是团队的一部分。
The stand-ins are really a part of the world of that stage.
替身确实是那个舞台世界的一部分。
In fact, when we would do rehearsals and run throughs when we didn't have the actors playing all the other side parts, the stand-ins would play those parts.
事实上，当我们进行排练和演练时，当我们没有演员扮演所有其他配角时，替身就会扮演这些部分。
They're actors, they're good actors.
他们是演员，他们是好演员。
Ron, Gita, and Evan, they were really good actors, and so they would run throughs in front of the studio and the network, and when they got a laugh, it was great, it helped our writing, it helped our performance of run throughs and rehearsals that they were so good, and then sometimes they were so good, we'd say, you're gonna do that part, and that's probably what happened.
罗恩、吉塔和埃文，他们都是非常好的演员，所以他们会在演播室和电视网面前演戏，当他们笑起来的时候，这很棒，这对我们的写作有帮助，对我们的演戏和排练也有帮助，他们太棒了，有时他们太棒了，我们会说，你要演那个部分，这可能就是发生的事情。
I bet Evan did it at the studio network run through, and we were thinking we're gonna cast someone, we said, screw it, we're not gonna cast someone, we'll just let Evan do it.
我打赌埃文在演播室网络中做到了这一点，我们当时想我们要选一个人，我们说，管它的，我们不会选一个人，我们会让埃文来做。
That happened a couple of times, that happened with Ron.
这种事发生过几次，罗恩也曾遇到过。
Every stand in, I mean, Ron had a recurring role at the TV.
我的意思是，每次替身，罗恩都会在电视上扮演一个反复出现的角色。
Yeah.
是的。
Ron was recurring.
罗恩再次出现。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I just want to say something about Ron, and he passed recently, and he was just a delight Ron Niccolosi.
好吧，我只想说一些关于罗恩的事情，他最近去世了，他是一个令人高兴的罗恩·尼科洛西。
He sure was.
他确实是。
And he was Neil's stand-in.
他是尼尔的替身。
And if you saw a picture of Neil and Ron next to each other, normally they try to get like same height, same build, like, because they have to light it, right?
如果你看到尼尔和罗恩并排的照片，通常他们会尝试变得相同的高度，相同的身材，因为他们必须照亮它，对吧？
So they want the framing to be and not be like he's not an NPH type.
所以他们希望框架是他不是 NPH 类型。
He's not an NPH type.
他不是NPH类型。
He was not.
他不是。
He would remember he would wear those heel, like he had like four inch fat foreign heels.
他会记得他会穿那双高跟鞋，就像他有四英寸厚的外国高跟鞋一样。
Yeah, like what Peter Boyle was wearing in young Frankenstein to try to get the heels high.
是的，就像彼得·博伊尔在《年轻的弗兰肯斯坦》中试图把高跟鞋抬高一样。
To be the right height, he was much shorter than Neil, yeah.
为了达到合适的身高，他比尼尔矮得多，是的。
And also when Neil, like either maybe Neil was out sick or something during a run through and Ron would do Barney, he would crush but in a totally different way than Neil because he had like a real New York or a Boston accent, right?
而且当尼尔，比如尼尔生病了或者在跑步期间发生了什么事情而罗恩会扮演巴尼时，他会迷恋巴尼，但方式与尼尔完全不同，因为他有真正的纽约或波士顿口音，对吧？
Wasn't he from Boston?
他不是波士顿人吗？
Boston accent.
波士顿口音。
And he had a real thick Boston accent.
他有浓重的波士顿口音。
So just a picture, a guy who doesn't look like Neil, gray hair, just crushing Barney, but in a totally different way than Neil.
所以只是一张照片，一个看起来不像尼尔的家伙，灰白的头发，只是压垮巴尼，但与尼尔完全不同。
So funny.
太有趣了。
Yeah.
是的。
So funny every time to the point where he had fans in the executives, like the studio and network went through is sometimes Alex Jaffe would whisper to me, she's like, oh, I see that Ron's going to have a lunch.
有趣的是，每次他在高管中都有粉丝，就像工作室和网络所经历的那样，有时亚历克斯·贾菲会对我低声说，她就像，哦，我看到罗恩要去吃午餐了。
I want to hear what Ron's going to do with this.
我想听听罗恩将对此做什么。
And she was like, oh, fan of Ron.
她就像，哦，罗恩的粉丝。
And this is all to say that we loved Ron and the RIP.
这就是说我们热爱 Ron 和 RIP。
And Gita also, Gita was, I think, Kobe's stand-in, or what's she, Ali's, I can't remember.
还有吉塔，我想吉塔是科比的替身，或者是阿里的替身，我不记得了。
But Gita was on the show, she will, she'll pop up, we'll point her out.
但吉塔在节目中，她会的，她会突然出现，我们会指出她。
He doesn't, you see Gita and all of them were on the show because they were all so good.
他没有，你看吉塔和他们所有人都参加了演出，因为他们都很棒。
They were great.
他们很棒。
They're such a part of the fabric of the show and they are good actors and they would score and run through and they'd help us out so much and then we'd often give them apart because they were so good in it or, you know, so there, the thank you guys.
他们是节目结构的一部分，他们是优秀的演员，他们会得分和贯穿，他们会帮助我们很多，然后我们经常会把他们分开，因为他们在其中表现得很好，或者，你知道，所以，谢谢你们。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Shout out to the stand-ins.
向替身们喊话。
stand-ins and an R.I.P.
替身和 R.I.P.
to Ron Ecollosi, who was a real heart and soul part of part of the team.
感谢 Ron Ecollosi，他是团队的核心成员。
Oh, hey, everyone.
哦，嘿，大家。
There's a little more.
还有一点。
There's a bonus to our bonus episode here.
我们的奖励剧集还有一个奖励。
If you are watching on YouTube, you'll notice we're all dressed differently.
如果您在 YouTube 上观看，您会发现我们的穿着都不同。
It is the next day because after we recorded our our general questions, general questions.
这是第二天，因为我们记录了我们的一般性问题，一般性问题。
That was me, honestly.
老实说，那是我。
So I just always thought about that one.
所以我一直在想这个。
We got an email from Chris Miller with a little more information about this episode and we were able to match up his answers with some more of your questions.
我们收到了克里斯·米勒发来的一封电子邮件，其中包含有关这一集的更多信息，我们能够将他的答案与您的更多问题进行匹配。
Chris and Phil were sorry they couldn't be with us.
克里斯和菲尔很遗憾他们不能和我们在一起。
We wanted to get them for that episode.
我们想让他们参加那一集。
Maybe we can have the two of them on for a special combo Lord Miller episode sometime in the future.
也许我们可以在未来的某个时候让他们两个一起参加米勒勋爵的特别组合剧集。
We'll see their post doing post on another huge amazing movie and Chris wanted to make sure he threw in a few tidbits and that's what this is.
我们将看到他们的帖子在另一部精彩的大电影上发表，克里斯想确保他添加了一些花絮，这就是这个。
All right.
好的。
So Hannah Joe Little asks, have any of you ever been arrested for public urination?
汉娜·乔·利特尔问道，你们中有人曾因在公共场合随地小便而被捕过吗？
I'll start it off because I was in the writer's room with Chris and I will say that I forgot almost all of this and was delighted with Chris throwing this out there.
我会开始它，因为我和克里斯一起在作家的房间里，我会说我几乎忘记了所有这些，并且很高兴克里斯把它扔在那里。
So he says, Chris's answer to that question is, Barney getting arrested was based on my brother-in-law, David Mergio.
所以他说，克里斯对这个问题的回答是，巴尼被捕是基于我的姐夫大卫·默吉奥。
You're welcome for the shout out here, David, who might have met in real life and is a lovely man.
欢迎您在这里大喊大叫，大卫，他可能在现实生活中见过，而且是一个可爱的男人。
the brother of Robin Murgio Chris' wife who is the loveliest person, but apparently one night, David Murgio, he got stopped by cops for peeing in the alleyway behind a bar in New York and was forced to do community service.
克里斯妻子罗宾·穆吉奥的兄弟是最可爱的人，但显然有一天晚上，大卫·穆吉奥因在纽约一家酒吧后面的小巷里撒尿而被警察拦住，被迫去做社区服务。
Again, David Murgio.
再次是大卫·穆吉奥。
We love him, we love Robin, we love Chris, and that is a blame Chris if David, if you're upset that we talked about that, you talked to Chris I love that he's like full he includes the full name You want to check this guy out he's on LinkedIn Abhajah Iprakash asks love the thanks teeny I haven't tried it But would like to tell me it tastes amazing.
我们爱他，我们爱罗宾，我们爱克里斯，这是克里斯的责任，如果大卫，如果你对我们谈论这件事感到不安，你和克里斯谈过，我喜欢他，他很完整，他包括全名，你想在LinkedIn上查看这个人，阿巴贾·伊普拉卡什（Abhajah Iprakash）问爱，谢谢我，我还没试过，但想告诉我它的味道棒极了。
I want Thanksgiving in my mouth.
我想把感恩节含在嘴里。
What is that from well Chris Chris writes It's the thanks, teeny was a gimmick we invented.
克里斯克里斯写的那是什么？这是感谢，微小是我们发明的一个噱头。
So Lily would have an excuse for barfing that wouldn't give away the pregnancy scare.
这样莉莉就有了呕吐的借口，但又不会暴露怀孕的恐惧。
And I made one to test it out.
我做了一个来测试一下。
The bullion cube was removed after five seconds.
五秒后金块被移除。
And it was, as you would expect, disgusting.
正如你所预料的那样，这很恶心。
I completely forgot about that, but that did happen, I think, in the room.
我完全忘记了这一点，但我想，那件事确实发生在房间里。
That was amazing.
太棒了。
Or maybe Krista at home, but yes.
或者也许克里斯塔在家，但是是的。
So there are many questions, of course, about the salad.
当然，关于沙拉还有很多问题。
And Takea Esshan asks, who came up with the salad recipe?
Takea Esshan 问道，谁想出了沙拉食谱？
Is that someone's actual family?
那是某人真正的家人吗？
recipe.
食谱。
Chris Miller writes visiting Marshall's family was based on a trip Phil and I took to visit our friend Lynn Ricketts.
克里斯·米勒写道，拜访马歇尔的家人是基于菲尔和我去拜访我们的朋友林恩·里基茨的一次旅行。
We're calling out everybody's name in here and her family in upstate New York.
我们正在喊出这里每个人的名字以及她在纽约州北部的家人的名字。
They made a seven layer salad that had mayonnaise and I think marshmallows and we thought it was like a foreign planet which is very much the spirit of what Lily feels.
他们做了七层沙拉，里面有蛋黄酱，我想还有棉花糖，我们觉得它就像一个外星，这正是莉莉所感受到的精神。
The salad we made for the episode had potato chips, gummy bears mayo and more.
我们为这一集做的沙拉有薯片、小熊软糖蛋黄酱等等。
Yes, I remember everyone had some had cross paths at some point with some salad kind of like there's a lot of people in the room, but I forgot specifically this.
是的，我记得每个人在某些时候都与一些沙拉有过交叉，就像房间里有很多人一样，但我具体忘记了这一点。
Lynn Ricketts, great salad, thank you for the inspiration.
Lynn Ricketts，很棒的沙拉，谢谢你的灵感。
Samuel Perez, 1909 says, this is one of those episodes that looks fantastic while watching it.
Samuel Perez，1909 说，这是观看时看起来非常棒的剧集之一。
But with all the tall people in this episode specifically, how are what changes did you make to make everyone seem bigger?
但是对于这一集里所有的高个子，你做了什么改变让每个人看起来都更大了？
And what are some of the challenges to capture Alison compared to the tall talent around her.
与周围的高大人才相比，捕捉艾莉森有哪些挑战？
And Jessica Wallace, XOX similarly asks, when you cast Marshall's family, did you just request quote the tallest actors of all time?
杰西卡华莱士，XOX 同样问，当你为马歇尔的家人选角时，你是否只是要求引用有史以来最高的演员？
Chris writes, the big thing that we thought was funny was little Alison imagining giving birth to a giant baby.
克里斯写道，我们认为有趣的一件大事是小艾莉森想象生下一个巨大的婴儿。
So the episode was mostly about casting the tallest people we could.
所以这一集主要是为了挑选我们能找到的最高的人。
So Marshall was the shrimp six foot for Jason Seagull.
所以马歇尔是杰森海鸥的六英尺虾。
And we learned we got character payments.
我们得知我们获得了角色报酬。
Every time a character we introduced in our script was reused, so we were very excited to cast the brothers.
每次我们在剧本中引入的角色都会被重复使用，所以我们很高兴能选到这对兄弟。
And every time they came back, we would high-five them because they were getting work and we were getting like a hundred dollars.
每次他们回来，我们都会向他们击掌，因为他们正在上班，而我们得到了大约一百美元。
Yeah, and those guys really still need that hundred bucks because they've only each won one Oscar apiece.
是的，这些家伙确实还需要那一百美元，因为他们每个人都只赢得了一次奥斯卡奖。
I don't know that I knew that, that if you introduce a character in your episode and then they recur, you get a little.
我不知道我是否知道这一点，如果你在剧集中引入一个角色，然后他们再次出现，你就会得到一点。
Yeah, yeah, we get them for this character we created Ted Mosley.
是的，是的，我们为我们创造的特德·莫斯利这个角色得到了它们。
I think you should just sign those checks over to me.
我认为你应该把这些支票签给我。
We can talk out a week and we can cut that part out right now.
我们可以讨论一周，然后我们现在就可以删掉那部分。
Nope.
没有。
Apparently I don't edit.
看来我不会编辑。
We get people offering to edit this show all the time.
我们一直有人主动提出剪辑这个节目。
Nellit Win 4 says, this isn't specific to the episode, but I'd love to hear more about the music selection for him, yeah, and how the music supervisor job worked.
Nellit Win 4 说，这不是特定于这一集的，但我很想听到更多关于他的音乐选择的信息，是的，以及音乐总监的工作是如何运作的。
I've sort of chosen that as a question to lead into this information we got about some music in the episode.
我选择这个问题来引导我们了解有关该集中一些音乐的信息。
This is what Chris says.
克里斯是这么说的。
This is a story about the band, the 88, that Chris and who Chris and Phil were friends with and helped us out a few different times on him.
这是一个关于 88 乐队的故事，克里斯和菲尔是这支乐队的朋友，并多次帮助我们摆脱了他的困境。
And Chris says, okay, so I'll tell T it up since it wasn't the question early T it up.
克里斯说，好吧，所以我会告诉 T，因为这不是早期的问题。
In Belly Full of Turkey, you hear the song Mr. Roboto, which is a hilarious song to be playing in a strip club.
在《Belly Full of Turkey》中，您会听到歌曲 Mr. Roboto，这是一首在脱衣舞俱乐部播放的搞笑歌曲。
I just love that I'm on Thanksgiving.
我很高兴我在感恩节。
That's the song she's dancing on a strip club.
这是她在脱衣舞俱乐部跳舞的歌曲。
And the idea was gonna be that we would then, At the end of the episode have the sweet touching song be like this really sort of indie rock acoustic slow emotional version of Mr. Roboto and the 88 who are awesome dudes said we'll make that for you.
我们的想法是，在这一集的结尾，我们会播放一首甜美动人的歌曲，就像这首独立摇滚原声缓慢情感版本的 Roboto 先生和 88 位很棒的家伙说我们会为你制作这首歌曲。
That's hilarious.
太搞笑了。
We'll do it.
我们会做的。
And they made like actually a really moving pretty sounding version of Mr. Roboto.
他们实际上制作了一个非常动人、声音优美的机器人先生版本。
Chris says about it.
克里斯谈到了这一点。
The craziest thing is because of the Mr. Roboto reference earlier we all thought it would be cool to get the 88 to cover Mr. Roboto final scene Adam and Keith who run that band I think did it.
最疯狂的事情是因为早些时候提到了 Mr. Roboto，我们都认为让 88 来覆盖 Mr. Roboto 最后的场景会很酷，我认为他们是那个乐队的运营者 Adam 和 Keith。
And it's awesome, but ultimately their song You Belong To Me was more emotional, but I always regret we didn't get to unleash a cover on the world.
这太棒了，但最终他们的歌曲《你属于我》更加情绪化，但我总是很遗憾我们没有向世界公开翻唱。
I still haven't and use it in playlists sometimes.
我仍然没有使用它，有时会在播放列表中使用它。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yes, and thank you Chris Miller for sending us all of that, and we've got a few more questions answered.
是的，感谢克里斯·米勒向我们发送所有这些信息，我们还得到了其他一些问题的答案。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请装备我，所有的罪孽都被宽恕，在纽约。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumber.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人（又名 Gen Z Master）是 Emily Blumber。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
really does help the show.
确实对节目有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的《Muse Letters》，在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠小说上订购克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 的处女作，你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》(Dead Fathers Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。